nessa murphy first broke the story of
terrell rhodes alleged confession
and arrest but we begin with victoria
saha live from the
area where amari was found earlier this
afternoon
brian i'm at segal suites where amari
was found just after one o'clock this
afternoon there was a huge police
presence
and this is right next to emerald suites
the last known location of omari
after an extensive search for amari he
was found
behind this wall crowds gathered when
the news broke about amari's body being
discovered
strangers watched amari was as he was
placed into a funeral home car yelling
we love you amari
there were so many emotions today coming
from people who have been following this
case for a week
and themselves have gone and searched
for any clues that may have led them to
amari
i spoke to a woman here who lives close
by she tells me
she was handing out flyers this week and
as devastating of an end this is
she's glad amari was finally found
my heart is broken for this baby and his
family
we've been i've been helping pass out
flyers
and we've walked and looked we've
checked our trash cans we've looked
everywhere
it's too close to home
as a scene cleared off at the seagull
sweets amari's mom taylor nicholson
showed up at the mcdonald's next door
and it appeared police were talking to
her the crowd gathered there and was
very emotional but she did not appear to
be crying or in shock
and then drove off i was out here on
saturday as volunteers handed out flyers
of course
they're all very upset they couldn't
find amari earlier
reporting live from segal suites
victoria saha 8 news now
victoria